welcome to this video playing em ho bro
from Denmark he's playing the Chi Gorean
variation and against the French very
related line related to the Kings Indian
attack I'm trying to block the center
here the 65 is a loss of a temple but
still you would like to get this central
control um should I go d5 he actually I
haven't played the six maybe should use
that why not okay yeah h6 is almost
universally useful in this type of
position for preventing Bishop g5 and
then moves like that uh-huh so I can go
deform and I'll do that
and that's not see not he's not taking
okay all right so what does this next
move maybe night h 4 + f4 this would be
quite typical be five maybe he's playing
a form i can take on c3 played before
okay maybe look some looks interesting a
phone i'm taking here takes be 594
should be hmm as this got spam not sure
actually hmm ok it's not going for that
alright so here at that's interesting i
can also take with the pawn to yeah yeah
to get see fine quickly see form this is
interesting because he has this somewhat
somewhat awkward setup with the Queen on
each wearing I'm intending bishop a six
now and then c4 but he's them on d4 many
times it's not like I have fun this I
cannot play this um easily still I'm
going to prepare to prepare it okay here
we go
okay if I take now play the play before
and yeah that's not so convincing I
should probably increase the pressure a
bit okay maybe he will play e6 um okay
this was the idea getting it allowing it
to e6 and then just play a five to have
a position where the 97 is blocking this
and what is he doing now I mean there is
no direct way before know you will take
the three that's not really on yeah
I don't don't see a good way to increase
it the pressure how to do that look here
maybe going try to to win the porn
actually is Bishop 21 he cannot play
Bishop f4 or something like that yes
this one if I go night before if it
takes i have d 3 Wow not sure takes pawn
takes should be good for me and these
six hangs okay maybe it gets tense
whether this is this he played really
quickly maybe maybe I didn't assess this
correctly d three I mean I played it
rather quickly so let's see take here I
can take a to as long okay let's let's
take your first maybe you can play c5
okay that's that that's over here and
play would be to tending lucky too
yeah that's that's a real complicated
really complicated position to c7 slum
children now we both have some
liabilities but it looks it looks rather
active again this was one idea that the
bishop is so strong on g7 I died his his
have got everything hanging now and the
sea point is not not an immediate
problem right here maybe cover
everything a three-night situ on ITA
even ok I'll go here I go there and have
before coming ok nitey to check time
morning [ __ ] ok the sea pawn I can take
it I'll still take it it's not just I
have I have so much extra points already
so I don't check mine to give up to cap
they exchanged here this is a checkmate
should run into that look f7 made yeah
come on the deep bond should see the
deal here right
don't tell me that this is not promoting
okay check check check
yeah that that that's relatively easy no
white resigned all right well this was
complicated I'm probably in this type of
position where they're all pieces on the
board absolutely all no exchanges and
that's that's a use chance that we both
played both played some some some
mistakes very very lightly he's playing
all this moves out well let's see what
he's saying I felt like this should be a
man it's tricky for me now to to do any
analysis with him moving the ball I know
he has stopped examining okay here let's
check briefly this kind of position yeah
my computer gives this as almost winning
yeah it looks this looks strong actually
I get the pawn I get the pawn okay and
here what a mess em what a mess no Queen
yeah yeah comsys black wins minus four
yeah maybe this is the case I mean
here's a very bad night here and this is
a big threat and it's it's it's almost
impossible to prevent but it still felt
felt really murky to me and this is a
nice move I didn't think of that really
this received more material he has no
square for the rook funny okay but this
was always winning somehow I got a
complicated stuff but check couldn't
couldn't really screw it up anymore
alright thanks for watching